Amigos, amigas, os hago una pregunta:
Cuando pensáis en Japón, ¿qué
es lo primero que se os viene a la cabeza?
Seguramente penséis en un país moderno,
avanzado, con una rica cultura.
Muchos pensaréis
también en el manga, los comics, los videojuegos
o los samuráis…
[Vamos, que seguramente tendréis una imagen
muy positiva.]
Sin embargo, todos los países tienen sus
luces y sus sombras, y hoy, aquí en VisualPolitik
vamos a hablaros de un tema del que muy poquitos
medios hablan: el revisionismo histórico.
El revisionismo es
la negación total o parcial de acontecimientos
históricos, normalmente negativos, llevados
a cabo por un país en el pasado.
Muchos países con pasados difíciles de digerir
se esfuerzan por ocultar la verdad, o tratar
de cambiar la versión oficial de los hechos.
Y Japón, amigos, es uno de ellos.
(Démosle una vuelta… Si pensamos en Japón
y su pasado, ¿qué se nos ocurre? Samuráis,
geishas, quizás el doble ataque nuclear de
Estados Unidos o, como mucho, el ataque de
Pearl Harbor - aunque sólo sea por la película.
Sin embargo, a la mayoría no se le ocurren
cosas mucho más allá de estos acontecimientos.)
Pero amigos, ¿sabéis lo que fue realmente
el Imperio de Japón?
Sí, vale, el precursor del Japón moderno
pero, ¿sabéis exactamente lo que significa
eso para el extremo oriente?
¿Sabías que todavía hay heridas
muy abiertas en los países que fueron víctimas
de Japón como China o Corea?
Atentos.
(IMPERIO DE JAPÓN, EL IMPERIO DEL HORROR)
Efectivamente, Habéis escuchado bien.
Durante la primera mitad del siglo XX y, especialmente
durante los años 30 y 40, Japón fue una
potencia imperialista y expansionista que
se dedicó a invadir países vecinos sin piedad.
Y cuando decimos sin piedad es algo literal,
sin ningún tipo de humanidad.
En esos años negros, las tropas japonesas
cometieron algunos de los más atroces atropellos
a la integridad humana, a la vida y a la identidad
de las personas.
Casi cualquiera de las peores cosas que os
podéis imaginar que pueda hacer un país,
las hizo Japón en sus colonias.
(Cosas como la esclavitud de trabajadores
para la industria y la minería japonesas,
la esclavitud de mujeres o cosas aún más terribles
como los experimentos del escuadrón 731 que
emplearon armas químicas con personas vivas.
Cosas que puedes creernos es mejor no reproducir
de forma más literal.
Tan solo en la ciudad china de Nankín, los
japoneses acabaron en dos meses con la vida
de 300.000 personas, y abusaron de más de
80.000 mujeres.
En los países invadidos el imperio japonés
impuso por la fuerza la cultura, el idioma
y el sistema político y legal de Japón.
Hasta se obligó a la gente a cambiarse de nombre.
Como podéis ver, hablamos de una etapa oscura
de miedo, atrocidades y violencia sin ningún
tipo de control ni límite. Los soldados y
los mandos intermedios tenían carta blanca.
Como resultado de todo esto, al menos 20 millones
de personas en Asia perdieron la vida a manos
de Japón. 20 millones de personas.
De hecho, durante la guerra los datos sobre
la falta de escrúpulos del ejército japonés
ponen los pelos de punta. Cerca del 40% de
los prisioneros de guerra estadounidenses
que caían en manos de los japoneses no consiguieron
sobrevivir. Para que os hagáis una idea en
Europa esa cifra fue de menos del 2%.
Y no penseis que esto fue ni mucho menos algo
casual. La explicación está en la cultura
japonesa milenaria conocida como bushido,
una cultura que desprecia a los soldados que
se rinden en combate.
Esto, amigos, es lo que explica también que
los soldados japoneses fueran famosos por
luchar hasta las últimas consecuencias.
Pero bueno, dejemos el pasado y vayamos al presente.Veamos porque Japón se sigue llevando
tan mal con algunas de sus ex-colonias. Por ejemplo, Corea.
El problema, amigos, es que digamos que Japón
no está dejando a sus ex-colonias pasar página,
por culpa precisamente del revisionismo histórico.
Desde el ascenso al poder del Primer Ministro
Shinzo Abe en 2012, Japón ha sorprendido
al mundo con una política de revisión y
negación de su propia historia muy, pero
que muy preocupante.
Pero… ¿En qué consiste? ¿Qué está haciendo
Shinzo Abe para cambiar o edulcorar su historia?
¿Son los japoneses de hoy realmente conocedores
de su pasado?
Veámoslo.
Shinzo Abe es ya una cara muy conocida.
Lleva
desde 2012 dirigiendo Japón y es conocido
sobre todo por su programa de políticas económicas,
más conocido como Abenomics.
Ahora bien, hay un aspecto de Shinzo Abe mucho
más controvertido del que no se habla demasiado
en occidente: Abe es un revisionista abiertamente
convencido.
(Y lo ha sido siempre. Desde que entró por
primera vez en la Dieta, el parlamento de
Japón, en 1993, Abe ha promovido leyes y
reformas que tratan de edulcorar la forma
en la que la historia del Imperio de Japón
se muestra a la sociedad.
Por ejemplo, en su primer y breve mandato
como Primer Ministro entre septiembre de 2006
y septiembre de 2007, Abe aprobó una reforma
de la Ley Fundamental de Educación, para
instaurar en el sistema educativo japonés
una visión más patriótica y con valores
morales tradicionalistas. Vamos puro nacionalismo en la educación.)
Y por si todo esto fuera poco, el propio Shinzo
Abe, el mismísimo Shinzo Abe es miembro de
Nippon Kaigi, un grupo ultranacionalista japonés
fundado en 1997 que defiende abiertamente
el revisionismo histórico para exculpar de
sus crímenes al Imperio de Japón.
[Vamos, algo así como si en Alemania Merkel
formase parte de un grupo cercano
a la extrema derecha radical.]
Pero, ahora bien, ¿pensáis que Abe oculta
acaso estas intenciones? Para nada.
(Los libros de texto de Estados Unidos desvían
la historia, dice el Primer Ministro de Japón.)
En efecto amigos, el Primer Ministro Abe no
solo modificó la Ley de educación japonesa
para cambiar contenidos de la educación,
sino que también critica abiertamente cómo
se aborda la historia de Japón en otros países.
[Vamos, que no se esconde.]
(El revisionismo de Abe se anota goles tanto
en casa como fuera. The Japan Times)
Incluso, el Primer Ministro japonés llegó
a arremeter contra la editorial McGraw-Hill
por la descripción que hacía de las mujeres
forzadas por Japón a prostituirse en la línea
de batalla.
Mujeres que, para él y los revisionistas,
no eran más que voluntarias que cobraban
mucho dinero, aunque todas las evidencias
históricas relatan que eran esclavas.
(“Acabo de ver el documento del libro de
texto de McGraw-Hill y me he quedado impactado.
Este tipo de libros de texto están siendo
usados en Estados Unidos porque no hemos protestado
por las cosas por las que deberíamos haber
protestado, y hemos fallado en corregir las
cosas que deberíamos haber corregido.”
Shinzo Abe, Primer Ministro de Japón)
Y no os creáis que esto fue un caso aislado…
El Japón de Abe lleva desde que llegó al
poder. implantando en las instituciones el
revisionismo más extremo, impulsado por el
grupo ultranacionalista Nippon Kaigi.
Sin ir más lejos en su discurso durante el
70º aniversario de la rendición de Japón,
Abe, citando la muerte de los 3 millones de
caídos por el Imperio de Japón, enalteció
sus sacrificios y los tildó de valiosos.
En ese mismo acto, por cierto, también habló
el entonces Emperador Akihito, que, claro,
es hijo de Hirohito, el Emperador que atacó
Pearl Harbor y desencadenó tantas guerras
a lo largo y ancho de Asia.
Pues bien, en contraste con Shinzo Abe, él
se mostró algo más abochornado por la deriva
revisionista de su país.
(“Nuestro país hoy disfruta de paz y prosperidad
gracias a los incansables esfuerzos hechos
por el pueblo de Japón hacia la recuperación
de la devastación de la guerra y hacia el
desarrollo, siempre apoyado por su fervoroso
deseo de continuación de la paz.” Emperador
Akihito de Japón.)
[Resulta curioso que el propio Emperador tenga
un discurso mucho más conciliador y humilde
que el primer ministro respecto al pasado
del imperio... ¿no creéis?]
Y eso no es todo,, tanto Shinzo Abe como muchos
ministros, diputados y senadores de su partido
visitan o envían ofrendas con regularidad
al Santuario Yasukuni.
Yasukuni es un santuario sintoísta donde
se honran, entre otros, a 14 criminales de
guerra de clase A del Imperio de Japón.
Criminales de guerra que fueron declarados
como tal en los Juicios de Tokyo, el equivalente
japonés a los Juicios de Nuremberg para los
nazis. Ahí es nada.
Pero, amigos, si pensais que todo esto es
una cuestión de discursos, palabras y visitas
a lugares controvertidos, estáis muy pero
que muy equivocados.
Atentos.
(EL SUEÑO POR CONTROLAR LA EDUCACIÓN)
Así es amigos, no es ningún secreto. Todo
gobernante con aspiraciones de cambiar la
historia necesita influir
en la educación.
Ya os hemos contado que Abe modificó la ley
educativa con este fin, pero no os creáis
que se conformó solo con esto.
Uno de los mayores escándalos de su gobierno
fue el de la guardería de Osaka Moritomo
Gakuen.
Veréis, esta guardería privada, de ideología
ultranacionalista, adoctrinaba a los niños
con una educación al más puro estilo del
Imperio de Japón.
Incluso, atentos, se les hacía memorizar
diariamente el Rescripto Imperial sobre la
Educación de 1890, una especie de manifiesto
con principios del Imperio. ¡A niños de
5 y 6 años!
Pero, un momento ¿qué tiene que ver Shinzo
Abe con todo esto?
(Pues además de decir públicamente que compartía
visión ideológica con su director, Yasunori
Kagoike, Abe y su mujer, quién fue nombrada
directora honoraria de la guardería, se vieron
inmersos en un escándalo de favoritismo en
la venta de terrenos públicos para la guardería.
El escándalo de corrupción estuvo a punto
de tirar abajo el gobierno de Abe, aunque al final
logró mantenerse en pie y ser reelegido como Primer Ministro ese mismo año y cómo
presidente de su partido el año siguiente.
Pero, amigos, al margen del escándalo de
la guardería imperialista, en Japón existe
una especie de laguna histórica en el seno
del propio sistema educativo.
La profesora de historia Tamaki
Matsuoka, famosa por haber conseguido que
250 ex-soldados de la época del Imperio de
Japón admitiesen un montón de crímenes,
es experta en cómo se afronta el pasado criminal
de Japón en la escuela moderna.
Y amigos, sus conclusiones son muy desalentadoras.
Matsuoka acusa al gobierno de Abe de silenciar deliberadamente
los acontecimientos históricos más negativos
del Imperio de Japón.
Por ejemplo, en los libros de texto que los
estudiantes usan en las escuelas, se le dedica
un simple pie de página a la masacre de Nankín,
de la que os hablamos al principio del vídeo.
Y que queréis que os diga, 300.000 víctimas
parecen suficientes para que sea un hecho
relevante en los libros de historia, ¿no
os parece?
Pero, llegados a este punto, podemos plantearnos
una pregunta esencial, ¿Qué efectos puede
tener este silencio histórico?
Sí, aunque en VisualPolitik
lo que mas nos guste es hablar del presente,
de los cambios que se están produciendo hoy en todo el mundo.
Vamos que alguno podría pensar que no somos muy fans de mirar hacia atrás.
ignorar una parte importante de la historia
tan trascendental puede llegar a ser peligroso
a la hora de tomar decisiones políticas.
Especialmente en una región del mundo con
tantos sentimientos nacionales.
Y si además los productos culturales están
también empañados por visiones históricas
revisionistas promovidas por el propio gobierno...,
entonces la cosa se complica todavía más.
(Películas y series como por ejemplo The
Eternal Zero dónde se ensalza la figura de
los pilotos kamikazes son prueba de como las
versiones nacionalistas y tergiversadas de
la historia están empapando hoy a la sociedad
japonesa.
Un fenómeno que junto a las tensiones políticas
y comerciales de la zona parecen estar alimentando
el sentimiento nacionalista entre los jóvenes
japoneses e incrementando su recelo hacia
sus países vecinos.. Hoy los estudios sociológicos
dicen que el 80% de los japoneses tienen una
mala imagen de China, cifra que asciende a
casi el 60% en el caso de Corea del Sur)
Amigos, tras conocer todos estos detalles,
¿qué pensáis sobre el modo en que Japón
está afrontando su pasado? ¿Entendéis por
qué los asuntos históricos son en realidad
un tema de actualidad, heridas sin cerrar?
¿Debería Japón aprender de Alemania para
afrontar su historia?
Dejad vuestra opinión aquí debajo en los
comentarios y, si os ha gustado este vídeo,
no olvidéis darle like.
Un saludo, y hasta la próxima.